et bien changements de camps nous sommes
plus à saké au mais dans un camp
beaucoup plus grand toujours en
territoire thaïlandais cawi d'angle
environ 130 mille réfugiés se trouvent
dans ce camp et tous ceux panneaux de
photos que vous voyez c'est à retrouver
les enfants perdus que si vous êtes
responsable de ce centre de recherche
est-ce qu'il ya beaucoup de gens qui
peuvent retrouver leurs enfants grâce
aux panneaux mais bien sûr monsieur il
ya beaucoup de personnes du 2e tour et
son enfant qui était perdue mondiale des
personnes par jour portant le nom de
vente et des enfants qui sont parfois
quasi depuis très longtemps
oui mais il y en a beaucoup et jean
kiffer a perdu depuis 1999
et puis soudain mon but césar n'ont de
sens et alors ils ces enfants se
trouvent forcément dans ce camp pas
obligatoirement un ils sont lents
d'autres dans d'autres contrées nous ce
sont les enfants qui sont venus de
toutes les femmes en finlande c'est
savez le cameroun
malouda pourtant conséquents et bien je
vous propose précisément de voir comment
l'on vit à la der de ce camp de karoui
d'en vivre hakaui donc c'est être
condamné comme cette jeune porteuse
d'eau à croupir dans une cahute rendu
insalubre par les tornades de la mousson
car oui donc sans doute le plus vaste
camp de réfugiés dans le monde
il avait été créé en novembre 79 sous la
poussée des vagues de cambodgiens fuyant
la famine et la guerre dans leur pays
depuis l'automne dernier tant bien que
mal la vie s'est organisée dans le camp
dont tous les habitants y compris les
bonzes sont considérés par la thaïlande
non comme des réfugiés politiques
mais comme des immigrants entrés
illégalement dans le pays
ainsi derrière une sérénité de façade
vit-on hakaui dang dans la hantise de
l'expulsion du refoulement brutale à
défaut de trouver un de ces pays
d'accueil qui ressemble à la terre
promise mais restent inaccessibles à
l'immense majorité des réfugiés
alors évidemment à l'abus de reportages
tel que celui-ci vous vous demandez si
n'est pas possible d'adopter un psycho
budget vous l'avez fait beaucoup les
dernières il faut dire générique c'est
très difficile c'est excessivement
difficile d'adopter l'heure actuelle et
petit cambodgien s'est pas tellement les
français fameux les français accordent
et bida assez facilement mais le haut
commissariat pour les réfugiés est très
réticent parce que on l'a retrouvé
beaucoup de parents pour des enfants qui
était soi disant cela on comprend qu'on
n'était pas là justement n'est pas sûr
effectivement que ses enfants soient là
où wall
alors vous vous êtes privilégier si je
puis dire car vous êtes venu un jour ici
dans si vraiment travaillé comme
bénévole au mois de mars comme un émoi
et puis si vous a plu ces tissus m'a plu
je savais que sa mère en tournoi c'est
son père donc vous cherchez à l'adopter
ce n'est parfait un crampon nation ce
n'est pas encore fait voilà je vous
souhaite bonne chance mais je crois
qu'il faut bien répéter aux
téléspectateurs c'est très très très
difficile à dôme étaient des petits
cambodgiens et puis y ait des problèmes
évidemment d'enracinement en france pour
vous ce matin de voir un autre aspect de
ce camp ici dans lequel nous sommes un
aspect disons peut être moins important
mais qui existent car ses sept
tentatives permanentes de récupération
de toutes les sortes d'église de sectes
d'organisations humanitaires de
récupération de ses quelque cent trente
mille personnes qui nous entourent
je vais voir l'exemple
il n'est peut-être pas le bon à suivre
de l'église du septième jour l'église
adventiste
jésus est omniprésent à l'hôpital
adventiste de kaui d'ong comme si les
médecins
doutant de leur art sollicité quelques
intervention miraculeuse
alors la consultation dans une salle
bondée de malades dont l'état requiert
pour la plupart calme et repos une
animatrice se livre à de bruyantes
activités de patronat
bien
tant pis les atlantistes font partie de
ces nombreuses organisations religieuses
présentes
akkaoui dang certaines y déploie un zèle
missionnaire très remarqué auprès des
réfugiés
il paraît qu'il ya eu beaucoup de
conversion c'est vrai ça deux champions
qui sont devenus adventices travail je
crois l'avoir ici car beaucoup de
cambodgiens
mais beaucoup de mes chiens comment vous
expliquez ça pardon comment vous
expliquez ça pour quoi
comment ça se fait ils deviennent tous
adventices pour ça
la cause de la dispa de la provence elle
est forte la propagande en belgique ou à
défaut une propagande qui se déploie
auprès des plus jeunes
sans épargner les bus apparemment
efficace
elle aurait abouti à une vague de 15000
à 20000 conversion aux différentes
sectes surtout les baptistes et les
adventistes dans le seul camp de qaïda
non
et qui plus facile pour les réfugiés
d'émigrer aux états unis quand ils
deviennent adventiste
non peut-être certains se convertit dit
dans ce 8 mai cela croyez moi ne les
aide pas cette concurrence acharnée
entre organisations religieuses y a
quelque chose de choquant savez ne date
pas d'hier elle remonte à plusieurs
siècles